honor glory lies to me idiot boys want
knighthood an idiot girls spread their
legs for it let me tell you what makes a
night killing either enough men or the
right man House Clegane should know were
very good at both most families claim
some great ancestor so far back that
nobody can prove them liars
not us my grandfather kept the kennel
for a Lord Titus Lannister of Casterly
Rock the father of Lord Tywin Lord Titus
was a weak man who didn't know it one
day while hunting he stumbled on a
lioness instead of embracing the man who
wore her on his banners she tried to
tear out his throat lucky my grandfather
came up with the dogs and drove the big
cat away as a reward the games got lands
and a keep and a son to Squire for the
Lannisters we took the three hounds who
died for them as our new sigil when
Tywin Lannister became Lord of Casterly
Rock he wanted more from his former
kennel master than fealty he bet the
training hounds to kill isn't far from
training boys to kill in just two
generations my brother Gregor and I
proved him right I gutted my first man
at 12 years after seven started
disappearing in our keep and even a
sister I don't remember but nobody could
prove anything against Gregor or dared
if they caught him at it for my father
wanted a night in our family and thought
he'd found one and Gregor who had 13
towered over enough men that they called
him the mountain sure Gregor looks quite
the champion from a distance but a
mountain can't leave a man in half with
one blow and won't break her wenches
face if she talks through Lord Tywin's
influence prince rhaegar targaryen
kindly anointed my brother personally a
great honour far
family everyone said one year later sir
Gregor shivers Lee sacked the princes
City brained the princes baby and raped
and murdered the princes wife winning
our family yet more honor from the new
king and queen soon after my father died
they say in a hunting accident the same
day that Gregor became Lord of the
Clegane lands gold and anything under
his roof I left our home to take service
at Casterly Rock nor Tywin is not like
his father
neither is King Joffrey or the likes of
me would never be on the King's Guard
with all those true Knights between them
a man who serves the Lannisters will
never lack for killing I'll guard this
king such as he is Gregor will kill the
other ones such as he does when we're
done who see how many people still
believe in songs and fairytales